Nothing says Ramadan like a good old
bomb-a-thon.
Jihadis from Pennsylvania.
Yes, we have Pennsylvania Jihadis in
2026.
First, we had Illinois Nazis.
Illinois Nazis?
I hate Illinois Nazis.
Now, we have Pennsylvania Jihadis.
What's next? California Commies?
Oh my goodness, there are tons of
California Communists.
South Dakota Satanists?
Great day in the morning, there are
South Dakota Satanists.
Mexican white supremacists?
Okay, I give up. This is bad and I blame
Mike Winger.
But, back to the Pennsylvania Jihadis
who pledged allegiance to ISIS and tried
to bomb protesters in front of Mayor
Zulfan Mamdani's mansion.
Ramadan 2026 started in New York City
with Muslims gathering for a prayer show
in Times Square where they openly
fantasized about slapping Christians.
What did Christianity teach you? Let me
teach you. Let me show you something.
Come and bring your cheek over here so I
can slap it and you can turn the other
cheek.
And it's only gone downhill from there.
On Saturday, protesters gathered outside
the mayor's mansion to protest Islam.
Counter protesters gathered to protest
the protesters and Jihadis threw bombs
to prove once and for all that the
protesters are wrong because Islam is a
religion of peace and tolerance.
Counter protester and all around useful
idiot Walter Masterson sums things up
perfectly when he posted
"I was in the middle of saying, as a
born and raised New Yorker, we welcome
everyone into this city When he threw
that over my head.
Through what?
Let's find out.
We were born and raised in New York, and
we want everyone here to stay in New
York. You don't get to come from outside
and then tell everyone else
Let's watch that again.
We were born and raised in New York, and
we want everyone here to stay in New
York. You don't get to come from outside
and then tell everyone else
Notice how the jihadi uses the useful
idiot to vault himself higher as he
throws his IED like a girl.
Kind of fitting, don't you think?
Jihadis physically using the people
they've been psychologically using for
decades.
After throwing one IED, Akayed Ullah,
whose parents moved here from Turkey,
ran to his partner, Ibrahim Kayoumi,
whose parents moved here from
Afghanistan, to grab a second IED.
But police charged.
Fortunately for everyone, Dumb and
Dumber jihadi edition didn't spend much
time learning how to make the IEDs, so
the devices didn't detonate properly.
And the pea-brained pair instantly
started self-snitching.
Both defendants have admitted that they
acted on Saturday because of ISIS. As
Kayoumi was being placed into an NYPD
vehicle, a person in the crowd asked why
he had done this.
Kayoumi responded with ISIS. After being
advised of his Miranda rights and waving
those rights, Kayumi said in recorded
post-arrest statements that he had
watched ISIS propaganda on his phone and
that his actions that day were partly
inspired by ISIS. On route to the NYPD
precinct, Balot made spontaneous
statements without being questioned by
NYPD officers that were captured on
body-worn camera footage. He said, "This
isn't a religion that just stands when
people talked about the blessed name of
the prophet. We take action. We take
action." And later, after waving his
rights, he requested paper and wrote a
message declaring, in part, "I pledge my
allegiance to the Islamic State. Die in
your rage, you Kuffar." He also told
investigators that he had hoped to carry
out an attack even bigger than the
Boston Marathon bombing, which he noted
resulted in only three deaths. Mayor
Adams
was quick to label the protesters white
supremacists.
On Saturday, a protest was held outside
Gracie Mansion, where I live with my
wife Rama.
Neither of us were home at the time.
This was a vile protest rooted in white
supremacy entitled "Stop the Islamic
Takeover of New York City." But
shockingly, he also condemned the
jihadis.
Two men, Amir Balot and Ibrahim Kayumi,
traveled from Pennsylvania and attempted
to bring violence to New York City.
They are suspected of coming here to
commit an act of terrorism.
Let me say this plainly.
Anyone who comes to New York City to
bring violence to our streets will be
held accountable in accordance with the
law.
See, I told you Adams was a moderate. At
least while his wife is under scrutiny
for celebrating the October 7th
massacre,
of course,
there's a far worse response to the
attacks than Mondani's, and it comes
from CNN, the most trusted name in
opposite world. Check out CNN's
description of Saturday's attack.
Two Pennsylvania teenagers crossed into
New York City Saturday morning for what
could have been a normal day enjoying
the city during abnormally warm weather.
But in less than an hour, their lives
would drastically change as the pair
would be arrested for throwing homemade
bombs during an anti-Muslim protest
outside of Mayor Zohran Mondani's home.
Here's what we know so far.
Oh, those poor teenage terrorists.
Their whole day was ruined by them
throwing bombs at people.
CNN eventually deleted the post, but
even after they deleted it, they
pretended that the attack targeted
Muslim Mayor Zohran Mondani.
Two Republicans say Muslims don't belong
here after an attempted terror attack
against New York's may Mayor Zohran
Mondani. After an attempted terror
attack against New York's [music]
Mayor Zohran Mondani. After an attempted
terror attack against New York's
Mayor Zohran Mondani and the House
Speaker Mike Johnson says nothing really
to condemn those comments. Yes, if
Walter Masterson, the bumbling [__]
that Amir Baluch used to help launch his
IED with his limp-wristed throwing style
were a news network,
he would be CNN, the network that's been
propping up jihadis for decades.
Let's all be thankful that due to 40
generations of first cousin marriage,
these jihadis aren't very bright, which
is why their attacks fail so frequently
and so miserably.
I wish Ramadan were simply the month
when Muslims gorge themselves with food
and pretend they're fasting,
but it isn't.
It's also the month when jihadis believe
their rewards for slaughtering
unbelievers in the name of Allah are
multiplied.
Maybe we can convince them
that if their rewards for good deeds are
multiplied during Ramadan,
maybe their punishments for humiliating
defeats
are also multiplied during Ramadan.
You're
>> [music]
>> trying to wind me up. You're trying to
wind me up. You're
trying to wind me up. It is not finally.
You're trying to wind me up. You're
trying to wind me up. You're
trying to wind me up.
>> [music]
>> It is not finally. This is a part of
religion. There's a reason to it. Yeah?
Yeah?